sir we're under arrest for the attempted
murder
the man out there you have the right to
remain silent I mean can you say Canon
will be used against you in a court of
law yes
[Music]
a lawyer for one of the survivors of
serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer is speaking
out after the release of Netflix's
monster a retelling of the True Crime
Story starring Evan Peters
that's what I'm getting what's coming to
me huh in 1991 after a traumatizing
night of captivity Tracy Edwards managed
to escape Dahmer the only victim who
made it out alive
help me
you tried to kill me
it's the moment that led police to
finally arrest Dahmer who up until that
time killed 17 victims over 23 years
that him
my name's Jeff right
you handcuff this man now over 30 years
later Tracy's former lawyer Paul
Kaczynski is sharing the Dark Truth
behind Tracy's recovery
Paul tells Fox News digital quote Tracy
could never get his life together again
after that it destroyed his life
Paul says Tracy struggled with drugs and
alcohol in the aftermath of the trauma
and recalled Tracy having no home he
says Tracy simply drifted from place to
place
ultimately Paul says he thinks Tracy
suffered from PTSD and added quote Tracy
didn't ask to be a victim of dahmers why
are you wearing handcuffs
they tried to kill me
the Ryan Murphy created True Crime
Series has become Netflix's biggest
debut with over 196 million hours
streamed in its first week and now the
platform is adding more content about
the murderer conversations with a killer
the Jeffrey Dahmer tapes Jeffrey Dahmer
was a very complex person
I wish I could give you a good
straightforward answer about that it's a
three-part documentary out October 7th
largely told through Dahmer's own words
are every little world
and complete control it also features
appearances by his legal team and
experts
there are times that I felt like a
mother to him I felt like I was his
therapist but hearing the graphic detail
was more than I could stand but
noticeably absent family members of the
victims
director Joe Berlinger explains quote
most did not want to participate most
either did not respond or declined and I
can understand why Joe promises his
project will be responsibly told and
sensitive to the victims quote I
certainly don't expect them to watch the
show but if they do I hope they will
feel like we treated their loved ones
with respect people were shocked they
were odd and they couldn't turn away
foreign